that's right gumby
towing the slab and the boogie down here
tonight will be his 28 start for jordan
montgomery and you you see that record
which is very deceiving michael covered
that in our pre-game a five and six
record does the rest of those numbers no
justice at all here comes the 3-2
stroke him out swinging one away
one two
swing and a miss curve ball two-way
right on cue get ahead
get him to chase either the curveball or
the change up his two best pitches and
it's really the location and the
tunneling effect of this curveball that
makes it so effective
all right andy abanez steps in now and
he goes after the first pitch puts this
one into short center field and it drops
in in front of gardner and ibanez with a
very soft single
here with the first
hit sharply and grabbed nicely by
urchella he'll go to second to get the
force
and that will do it no run to hit one
man left texas nothing yankees coming
back dane dunning this season 24 games
this will now be his 23rd start of the
season 5-8 record let's see that four
point two eight era frame 107 in the
third innings dj lemay hue and he hits
this one on the ground third base
jani hernandez plenty of time
to throw him out one away
well here is judge
he's at 287
35 homers 86 rbis runner goes 3-2 that
one's driven deep to right center field
on the run tavares on the track he can't
make the play
rizzo held up
so it'll be a double for judge and rizzo
advances to third
here's stanton second and third one man
out in field is back they'll give up a
run on the ground ball and the o2
shattered back ground ball
to short he activated first an rbi for
stint
crossing the plate is rizzo and the
yankees lead one done
ground ball let's see if they turn two
there's one on the first
not in time
and the yankee's going to challenge so
they think he's out
lemay you're pretty good on the turn
another look
and they overturned it so it's a double
play
6-5-3
line drive that's a base hit
garcia cannot cut the ball off it goes
to the wall torres will be stopped at
third it's a double for gardner and the
yankees have runners on second and third
with one man out here's the 2-2 delivery
check swing did he go around he did
and urshela has struck out on a slider
that was not in the strike zone he
chased one down and away dunning got the
strikeout he really needed there
gets this one on the ground to short
stop kind of falafel long throw in time
that's a nice play
and isaiah gets le mayhew to end the
inning
and saves at least a run here's a
3-2 strut came out swinging montgomery
wins that battle with a strikeout
so far so good for jordan montgomery his
two best pitches are on point here's a
2-2
swing and a miss ball in the dirt
and tavares down on strikes so four
strikeouts
for montgomery here's stanton
that one is ripped down the left field
line it is a bullet home run by stanton
oh my a line drive right down the line
inside the pole
and the yankees lead to nothing it's a
stantonian home run don't blink
that is the third hardest hit home run
of the mlb season
big battle for montgomery first and
third nobody out two two count
swing and a miss so a strikeout of
garcia nice comeback from jordan
montgomery fell down 2-0 all the way
back to get in a position to get that
swing and miss on a curveball to the
plate three and two
and it's on the ground third base
they will get the out at first but the
rangers get their first run of the night
rizzo been hit by a pitch and popped up
to the catcher
there's a base hit to left field
for shell around third ashella scores
it's a base hit
and an rbi for anthony rizzo the yankees
lead three to one
this one on the ground third base diving
stop hernandez he'll go to second for
the force out there and that's all
they'll get great play by both in
theaters to get a force at second base
yanni diving toward the line to spear
that smash over the bag
bounce the throw to second but solak
stayed with it and stayed on the bag
one out of bouncer third base hernandez
goes to second again the relay to first
in time double play and the inning is
over a couple of nifty plays by yani
hernandez helps the rangers get out of
trouble in the fifth joey gallo leads
off for the x high drive off the bat of
gallo deep to right
a long home run into the second deck he
connects against his former team and
gives the yankees a 4-1 lead
hey he's pal joey where's the harvest
moon when you need it because this was a
moon shot now here is judge
all the yankees with first and second
one out
high drive right center field there it
goes
see ya a three-run home run for judge
a bomb through the raindrops and it's
7-1 yankees all rise
there comes the judge and when does 707
days feel like an eternity
when you're a big time big league
pitcher and you have not been able to
get on the mound because of injuries the
last time he pitched was in the 2019
alcs the 2-2 swing and a miss a nice
start to his return as he strikes out
trevino
[Applause]
1-2
swinging and a miss how happy is that
man
a long
trek back to health
then getting back onto that mound at
yankee stadium and working a scoreless
inning and ringing up two strikeouts but
they want to see more they want to see
how far he can go
and how many pitches they could get him
up to as ibanya swings at the first
pitch
right out to floreal who hardly had to
move one pitch one out here in the ninth
chop left side le mayhew
takes the out of first for the second
out as garcia advances to second
popped up shallow left
gardner makes a play ball game over
yankees win the
yankees
wins severino is back with two scoreless
innings
just has to feel like a million bucks
[Music]